big week on tap for president biden he's
closing in on the 100-day mark of his
presidency and gearing up for his first
pivotal address to congress this
wednesday
so how are americans grading his
presidency so far
well voters are split a new fox news
poll shows his approval rating at
54 percent that job performance lower
than barack obama's and george w bush's
but
a little higher than president trump's
and senator rand paul is blasting biden
for failing to keep his promise on unity
and bipartisanship well you know just a
couple of months ago we were hearing
from president
biden the newly inaugurated president
biden that he was going to unify the
country
and that we were going to work together
and have bipartisanship
i'm still waiting mr president i haven't
seen any of that i think what i've seen
so far is it's biden's way or the
highway
but biden is getting high marks from the
progressive left listen to what
congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
is saying now
president biden has definitely exceeded
expectations that progressives had you
know i'll be fraying i think
a lot of us expected a much more
conservative administration but the
active invitation and willingness
and collaboration with progressives
in his first 100 days for almost 100
days
has been very impressive that's her take
greg there's a little bit of new math
happening
on these polls take a listen to chuck
todd yesterday
do i have to surprise you yes just
listen and then we'll get you monday
dana
he took over and things seemed to smooth
out
some might argue they always would have
but it doesn't matter it's on his watch
and that has given him political capital
willie
because in our numbers here you see that
that is driving the overall positive
approval ratings he has
and anytime you're over 50 in this
polarized environment that's really
solid it's sort of the new 60
percent uh of the way when you and i
grew up in the 80s and 90s
53 is the new 60. what i think okay
first off what a dork
i mean to actually look at percentage of
polling like you know 53
is the new 60 if somebody ever said that
at a bar
you would throw them out uh look he
should be at 90 percent right now he has
the wind
and a fawning press at his back and he
can barely
beat the most media despised
president in history donald trump so i i
think actually he's kind of cruising
with a c
plus but for me i feel like i'm watching
a socialist version
of bad grandpa you know where a hardcore
radical
dons a fake old man costume and quickly
dismantles law and order
uh um the border our education system
our tax system
joe is basically che guevara with
polydent and hair plugs
and no wonder at aoc is beaming like a
kid at christmas because she's getting
everything she wants hanukkah and
kwanzaa i should add
so i think we've learned that the best
way to push a dangerous agenda
is to appear as the least dangerous
person on earth
a befuddled grandfather who needs a gps
to find the west wing
well and you know you bring up socialism
and shay guevara um there's another
person who thinks that this is how
things are going in the first hundred
days listen to kevin mccarthy jesse
he was on fox news sunday if i look at
the hundred days
it's more like a bait and switch the
bait was he was going to govern as
bipartisan but the switch is he's
governed as a socialist
all right jesse um do you agree
socialist
it's a good line and the media just
covers him as a moderate so he can do
whatever he wants and he'll always be
branded
as a moderate but dana biden should be
at 60
in this poll if he didn't open the
border
he's getting crushed by independence
only 22 percent of independence
thinks he's doing a good job on the
border policy
and 77 percent of all americans believe
biden is to blame for the border crisis
so it just goes to show you
what that is and just you know the the
how willing they are to just hurt their
own political standing in the country
just to turn
texas blue there were some other things
that jumped out at me
from the poll dana it said that by a 20
point
margin the american people support low
taxes and smaller government so i look
at that i'm like all right my people
here we go
and then the next question is by an
eight port margin
the american people support higher taxes
on the rich
and a bigger government to have joe
biden do the two trillion dollar
infrastructure plan
that is why they call polling an art
also
something that jumped out at me too dana
their uh two top issues
for the democrats are climate change and
racism
totally subjective unmeasurable
media driven and then the two top issues
for republicans are immigration and the
economy
concrete substantive issues that
actually affect the american people
it just goes to show how effective
the media propaganda and fear is
in putting the american people in a
trance and distracting them
from issues that drive midterm turnout
like immigration and the economy but i
don't put a lot of stock in first
hundred days
he's in the honeymoon period or for a
democrat that's just being a democrat
he's only done a few things he's only
spent billions on covet relief
he killed all the keystone jobs and he
opened the border that's
it he basically coasted on covet 19 and
took all the credit while operation warp
speed and the democrat
and republican governors did all the
work he has a light schedule he pokes
his head up once a while
reads off the teleprompter and then goes
back inside and lets the media do the
heavy lifting
at that point that is the fairest
assessment you could give
for the first hundred days and i
challenge anybody
who says otherwise all right well we'll
give that a shot right now because
i mean in juan in some ways can it can
can they have it both ways the
opposition to president
biden saying that uh he's governing as a
socialist way far left getting all these
things done but also
when you look at it as jesse points out
there's actually only one big
legislative effort that happened and
that was coveted relief
right so i mean so either he's busy as a
bee or he's sleepy joe but i don't so i
mean
i i don't know how that criticism holds
water the other thing that we heard in
all those sound bites
uh you know from uh congressman
mccarthy and others was oh you know we
thought he was going to be
more bipartisan a unifier and then you
look at the poll numbers from the fox
poll
and it says that biden they're about
split on whether or not biden has done
enough to reach out to republicans but
there's no
question it's overwhelming they say
republicans have done nothing to try to
work
i saw that with biden so i mean this is
you know an indication when you want to
you know curse him out for not being
bipartisan i think it's important to
tell the whole story
but on the whole issue of the 100 days
i'd have to say i think he's doing very
well
kovit's the number one issue for all
americans and right now what you have is
a situation where half of all
adults in the country have gotten at
least one shot i think it's 95 million
adults are fully vaccinated that's
that's pretty good
on a very important topic the number one
topic number two topic
let's just stay with the economy the
fact that he got the stimulus
deal done uh you know to me this is very
important
i should say that's the covent relief
deal because it put
money in people's pockets who were hurt
by the economic consequences
of the pandemic 160 million people
got checks weekly unemployment last week
was the lowest it's been in a year
so to me you know when you look at 54
there was jokes about 54 is the new 60
we live in very politically polarized
times
and the idea that even though
everybody's so
angry at each other that 54 percent of
americans can agree
that's pretty good degan it's also i
mean i've read a thing today about the
shortage economy meaning um there's all
sorts of things that are coming up short
right now um how do you measure the
first hundred days well there are seven
and a half million job openings that's
higher than the pre-pandemic level
because
businesses can't find workers we were
talking about that last week
to juan's point you can analyze these
num these polling numbers
in a different way so joe biden is
net positive meaning approval higher
than disapproval on four
issues coronavirus health care economy
foreign policy
he's net negative on guns border
security and immigration
what does that mean coronavirus health
care
economy and foreign policy joe biden is
merely
serving up stone cold trump leftovers
to the voters that's why he's polling
better on those issues
coronavirus vaccine health care vaccine
economy low taxes four trillion dollars
in stimulus
last year before joe biden ever entered
the white house
and foreign policy so say thank you joe
to donald trump and then one more thing
the reason is
biden is not polling better is because
he's completely screwed over
union workers you don't need to analyze
100 days you need to analyze
one day joe biden's first day in office
where as jesse said
he killed the keystone xl pipeline he
destroyed
thousands upon thousands of great paying
union jobs
and then he turns around with his
dishonest gun flapping
and starts promising great pay and union
jobs
if you just pass this infrastructure
plan which is a government takeover of
the energy industry
it tears up the oil and natural gas
mining uh pipelines steel workers those
jobs are going to go away that's why you
have the socialist in the ruby red
lipstick all excited
this country is going down the tubes and
the american people know it
bartender we'll have another round of
whatever dagan had right before the show